jetzt aber mal zu einem wirklich
wichtigen thema laufen ja in deutschland
eine hochemotionale angelegenheit die
linkspartei liegt jetzt im entwurf zu
ihrem wahlprogramm an alkohol werbung zu
verbieten
dafür gab es gerade einen fetten schütz
dort für diese idee die bild am sonntag
waren schon vor der entmündigung des
bürgers und das macht übrigens jedes mal
wenn der uneingeschränkte zugang zum
lieblings gift der deutschen irgendwie
eingeschränkt werden soll
denn hier ist ein deutsches kulturgut
jeden 23
schwarze gouda kulturgut ich glaub ich
kultur jeden tag ich wusste dass auch
nicht sterben 40 deutsche an den folgen
von alkohol jeden tag die gesamtschäden
des laufens kosten uns 60 milliarden im
jahr uns alle
deswegen macht man sich auch ein
bisschen einfach wenn man sagt jeder
darf sich doch so offen wie er will
seit fast zwei jahren sitzt eine
arbeitsgruppe des bundestages an der
frage wie könnte man den alkoholkonsum
in deutschland reduzieren
gute frage problem die alkoholindustrie
nimmt überraschung im bundestag offenbar
massiv einfluss die formulierung der
verkauf von alkohol an tankstellen und
in supermärkten wird beschränkt wurde
gestritten bundesverband der deutschen
spirituosen industrie schreibt im
wirtschaftsministerium
er freut sich dass einige kritikpunkte
offenbar aufgegriffen worden
wie nett dass sie sich freuen kurze
nachfrage seit wann dürfen die dealer
mitreden wenn es um drogen gesetze geht
in keinem westlichen industrieland ist
alkohol so rund um die uhr verfügbar und
so billig wie bei uns nur drei sachen
würden wirklich etwas ändern sagen
suchtexperten preise hoch weniger
werbung und verfügbarkeit einschränken
trotzdem ist die politik für eine
schäden ist weiter so wäre dass ich ein
thema für die grünen
ich freue mich darüber wenn junge
engagierte menschen heute die ich für
bier interessieren
ich ziehe meine frau gekümmert ja ja
keinen spaß
da kommt dann sofort ein
freiheitsbegriff ins spiel und wie
gesagt ein sehr emotionales thema im
grunde wie das tempolimit anhalt
aufnehmen
ich hab meine frau wirklich aussieht ein
argument von vielen außerdem kann man
das ganze natürlich auch als
standortvorteil für deutschland
betrachten trinkt technisch sind wir im
vergleich mit anderen ländern ganz weit
vorne
erst hab ich doch früher immer meinen
kindern vorgelesen kennen sie das
wie voll ist germany ganz ganz tolle
frau schließt mal kurz vor hier eines
tages beschlossen der bär und sein
freund der kleine besoffene tiger komm
wir machen eine weltreise
denn je zu hause ist ja alles voller
leergut und kotze auch nach schweden
aber da war es kalt und der sprit so
teuer dass die beiden sich zusammen nur
ein bier kaufen konnten
scheiß schweden sagte der bär und
erschossen huth 1 11 weiter ging es nach
frankreich aber da kriegt man nachts an
der tanke gar keinen alkohol mehr
dann nicht blöde frosch besser voran
gehalt in die türkei
dort wurden der bär und der tiger
furchtbar zusammengeschlagen weil man
sie für journalisten und andere gebiete
wir vielleicht dafür der kleine
besoffene tiger ich will zurück nach
germany denn nur in deutschland war
immer und überall wenig alkohol was wir
mehr aber der wert konnte ihn nicht mehr
hören
denn der inzwischen an leberzirrhose für
recht ende
[Applaus]